falls du genug von langweiligen Gemüse
hast dann probiere diesen Knoblauch
Brokkoli auf Ricotta ich verspreche euch
so ist wirklich jeder gerne Gemüse
knusprig puttrig weich cremig ihr seid
dumm wenn es nicht nachmachen alles was
wir dafür brauchen ist natürlich
Brokkoli Ricotta Semmelbrösel Nüsse und
Knoblauch die habe ich meinen Brokkoli
das ist wildbrokoli geht natürlich auch
mit normalen Brokkoli ab in den Topf mit
gesalzenem Wasser ein zwei Minuten nur
vorkochen hier in der Pfanne hinten gebe
ich ordentlich Olivenöl hinein und
Olivenöl etwas gehackten
knoblauchten wenn der Brokkoli schön
weich ist gebe ich ihm die Pfanne und so
kriegen wir jetzt noch ein paar Reste
darum dran jetzt nehme ich mir meinen
Ricotta einfach auf den Teller und
streichen schön dünn aus jetzt sollten
wir hier ordentlich Farbe dran haben
Brokkoli nehmen und einfach nach dem
Recorder Verteilen der Knoblauch aus der
Pfanne kommt oben drüber und im
restlichen Öl rösten wir ein paar
Semmelbrösel an so wie ein paar Nüsse so
haben wir jetzt noch mal einen schönen
Crunch erhalten den wir oben drüber
geben einfach ein bisschen verteilen
noch einen Touch Olivenöl drüber und
fertig ist der wahrscheinlich geilste
Brokkoli der Welt kommt sogar noch
krasser mit ein bisschen Limettensaft